police in Richmond Virginia are on alert
as several dozen members of a
pro-confederate group or do to rally
this morning to defend Richmond's
Confederate monuments including a statue
of Robert Ely counter protesters are
expected at the rally raising concerns
of possible violence like what happened
in Charlottesville last month Paula Reed
is on Richmond's Monument Avenue this
morning Paula good morning good morning
organizers are building this as a
heritage rally they're coming here to
try to protect the statue of Robert Ely
here in Virginia's capital now counter
protests are planned with members of
black lives matter and the anarchist
group and Tifa expected to descend on
the city argued interrupted Friday ahead
of Richmond's first rally for a
Confederate Monument since last month's
violence in Charlottesville less than a
hundred members of a group called CSA to
the new Confederate States of America
plan to show support for the Lee
monument in Richmond Tara brandão is one
of the organizers I hope nobody loses
their life tomorrow on either side I
really do
that's not why we came here we came here
to help the people who want to stand up
for the monuments and the heritage 32
year-old Heather hire lost her life
about 60 miles away in Charlottesville
last month she was there to protest
against the neo-nazis and white
supremacists at the unite the right
rally today's demonstration was prompted
by calls for Richmond to reassess the
placement of Confederate monuments on
its famous Monument Avenue I think
everybody needs to worry on Thursday
Richmond Police chief Alfred Durham said
he didn't know what would happen
Saturday because no permits had been
filed for the rally none of us in our
team here can stand here and tell you
what to expect and how we're going to
respond if a hundred people show up
that's a hundred different scenarios
Mandy can play out police have closed
off streets in the area and there are
only three entry points to the monument
although the open carry of firearms is
permitted in Virginia
police say protestors cannot have items
like sticks shields or helmets Virginia
Governor Terry McAuliffe come in enjoy
it
whatever you want I may not like what
you're saying but you know what you have
a right to do it but you do not have a
right to do violence after what happened
in Charlottesville the governor of
Virginia has temporarily banned protests
at the base of this statute for this
monument is located inside a traffic
circle and the Chief of Police says
anyone that steps on that grass will be
arrested Anthony Paula Reid in Richmond
Virginia Thank You Paula